they made me feel like I was a gang
member pretty much and they wanted to
document every single one of my tattoos
welcome to the best of the worst of 2014
most violent crime goes unsolved in
American this year our nation's law
enforcement personnel distracted
themselves with all kinds of things when
they could have been spending more time
busting murders and rapists instead I
didn't know whether it was a bank
robbery or there there was a serial
killer loose the way that they had come
in like that they brought their big guns
along to a raid at a San Diego strip
club and then spent hours photographing
the ladies and checking their paperwork
in order to protect patrons from
unlicensed dancers they asked us for our
licenses and then took down our social
security or information and then had us
all line up in the back of the dressing
room and take pictures in a Colorado
town cops funded their own jobs by
ticketing out-of-towners for hanging air
fresheners and other items from their
rearview mirrors and the road pirates
weren't too concerned about abiding by
the laws they enforce on others
shouldn't you be obeying the law that
you enforce you know common is set up
checkpoints nationwide not to catch
kidnappers but to make sure you're
wearing your seatbelt the Minnesota they
commandeered school buses to spot
seatbelt scofflaws Vegas they cut
internet access to a hotel suite and
then pretended to be repairman to gain
access to the room where the guests were
suspected of close your ears kids
betting on sports you're the worst of
the worst bed not sport they bloodied an
elderly man who crossed against a red
light in New York ticketed 328
jaywalkers in San Diego on a single day
in jail the jogging jaywalker in Austin
in other cities cops are actually
committing sexual assaults on duty so I
thank God that this is what passes for a
controversy in Austin Texas so what were
the best of the worst of what we missed
in 2014 sound off below and followed the
show on Twitter just like Johnny Owen
2014's featured follower pics is the big
shot with Twitter in me are you
twittering me punk